tf1 20 heures avec patrice duhamel
conseil de guerre à matignon pour lutter
contre la sécheresse
jacques chirac fait le bilan spécial tf1
à la veille du sommet franco allemand
le chancelier schmitt parle de ses
bonnes relations avec monsieur giscard
d'estaing triomphe de borg à wimbledon
à 20 ans le jeune suédois remportent le
plus grand tournoi du monde en trois
sets contre nastase cinquante mille
français pratiquer la plongée sous
marine en fin de journal des conseils de
sécurité
bonsoir tout sera mis en oeuvre pour
limiter les effets néfastes de la
sécheresse il n'y aura pas de pénurie de
fourrage et peu de risque de connaître
des ruptures d'approvisionnement en eau
tels sont les résultats essentiels du
conseil de guerre qui a réuni cet après
midi autour du premier ministre
huit membres du gouvernement une
quinzaine de préfet ce dont les
départements sont les plus frappés et
aussi quelques hauts fonctionnaires il
s'agissait d'abord pour jacques chirac
d'écouté de dresser le bilan de la
situation de recenser les besoins puis
de prendre les décisions et c'est en
réalité une nouvelle impulsion au plan
anti sécheresse qui a été donnée à
l'hôtel matignon où il faisait comme
partout en france très très très chaud
sans doute 36 à 37 degrés c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi des ventilateurs
avaient été installés et les volets de
la salle de réunion fermée
si le premier ministre a décidé de
donner aux préfets les pleins pouvoirs
pour qu'ils puissent sur place
régler avec la plus grande rapidité
possible tous les problèmes c'est que la
situation créée par la canicule ne
s'améliore pas au contraire les
spécialistes de la météo sont prudents
il ne prévoit guère de changement demain
les températures resteront comprises
entre 33 et 36 degrés un peu partout
dans le pays
et même si l'on attend des nuages
orageux ici et là rien de définitif ne
peut être avancée les agriculteurs
restent bien sûr malheureusement les
plus frappés pour les aider le
gouvernement a décidé de subventionner
de 40 à 55 % les transport de fourrage
au total écoutez bien ce chiffre 1
million de tonnes de paille vont être
transportés en quelques semaines un
million de tonnes
entre 30000 tonnes pour une année
normale mais le problème de l'eau est
également urgent d'autant que dans les
zones où les vacanciers sont en train
d'arriver entre parenthèses les départs
ne se sont pas trop mal passé dans ces
zones il faut penser au ravitaillement
d'une manière générale donc répétons le
les français ne risque pas de manquer
d'eau mais localement c'est le cas par
exemple à saint malo et à saint brieuc
quelques problèmes peuvent se poser on
va donc mobilisés partout tous les
moyens c'est ce que confirme marchegay
jacques chirac interrogé par jean
françois robin
il ya un problème de l'alimentation en
eau des agglomérations que nous avons
examinés et il est apparu que se réserve
de faire un certain nombre de travaux
rapides d'ailleurs qui ont été engagées
qui doivent se poursuivre à la diligence
des prêts faits pour lesquels nous avons
les crédits nécessaires
il n'y avait pas de risque sérieux
autres qu'accidentelle pour
l'alimentation le plus sérieux le
problème de l' incendie et il est apparu
que nous devions renforcer nos moyens en
matière de lutte contre un incendie ce
que nous avons fait en les donnant
naturellement au préfet qui sont dans
cette affaire vous savez les chefs de
file
mais il ya là un danger qui est grand et
l'ensemble de la population et notamment
il ya les campeurs tous ceux qui se
promènent pendant des vacances qui est
bien légitime doivent être extrêmement
prudent d'une part pour ne pas se mettre
dans une situation il pourrait être
victime d'un incendie subi et d'autre
part pour éviter bien sûr d'être
eux-mêmes à l'origine d'un incendie et
nous avons donc renforcé sensiblement
les moyens de prévention de détection et
de lutte contre la santé et c'était
d'ailleurs je voudrais rendre hommage à
l'action tout à fait exceptionnel que
mène actuellement l'ensemble de nos
pompiers et de nos services d'asante et
enfin il ya le problème fondamental qui
est celui de l'agriculture nous avons
pris vous le savez tout un ensemble de
dispositions et nous les avons
aujourd'hui renforcée je ne parlerai pas
des questions des revenus agricoles qui
feront l'objet vous le savez d'une aide
directe titre de la solidarité nationale
mais dont le montant et les modalités ne
seront fixés que au mois de septembre
fait un sceptre au revoir je nous avons
repris tout un ensemble de dispositions
ou renforcer aujourd'hui tout un
ensemble de dispositions de façon à
venir en aide aux exploitations
agricoles qui auraient des difficultés
particulières mais également pour
assurer dans toute la mesure du possible
une priorité pour ce qui concerne
affection l'affectation de l'eau à
l'agriculture et surtout pour mettre en
place et subventionner les transports de
fourrage qui sont indispensables pour la
survie du bétail et il est apparu
clairement que l'ignoré pas en france
cette année
deux problèmes réels de fourrage qui
n'ont pas de problème de pénurie de
fourrage en 1976-77 mais qu'en revanche
il y avait encore des dispositions à
prendre pour organiser le transport de
ce fourrage dans les régions qui en ont
besoin et qui en ont besoin et c'est ce
que nous avons aujourd'hui arrêter
ensemble je pense que sur ce point une
amélioration des situations se fera
sentir prochaine bref nous nous sommes
mais si vous voulez dans l'optique où la
sécheresse continuerai nous espérons
avoir une bonne surprise mais enfin nous
nous sommes mis dans l'optique où la
sécheresse continue ray et dans cette
hypothèse il faut évidemment éviter
toute insouciance il faut que chacun
soit conscient des contraintes qu'impose
la rareté une certaine rareté de l'eau
et donc accepté de ne pas gaspiller
l'eau et de l'affecter prioritairement
là où on en a besoin notamment en
matière agricole
mais d'autre part il ne faut pas non
plus se laisser aller à je ne sais quel
pessimisme ou a fortiori à je ne sais
quel affreusement qui ne serait pas du
tout de mise c'est ce qui est apparu
clairement dans la journée de bilan dans
la situation actuelle
cette vague de sécheresse continue
d'avoir des retombées dans tous les
secteurs de la vie nationale par exemple
la grève déclenchée par les conducteurs
d'autobus pour protester contre les
conditions de travail difficiles dus à
la canicule
cette grève s'est poursuivie aujourd'hui
à la touche et 10 sur les 23 dépôts de
la région parisienne
les machinistes on le sait veulent
qu'obtenir un cause de la chaleur une
heure de repos dans la journée dans les
régions les plus sinistrées on a décidé
d'interdire l'arrosage des pelouses et
le lavage des automobiles c'est le cas
par exemple dans la région du limousin
partout en france donc même avec des
moyens de fortune on s'efforce de
mobiliser les efforts et parfois on a
recours à la solution du désespoir on
prie pour que vienne la pluie c'est le
cas du petit village de saint siméon
dans le département de l'orne où la
situation des éleveurs est
particulièrement difficile là où
d'habitude l'herbe est verte et humide
les agriculteurs ont tout essayé mais
cela n'a pas suffi alors ils se sont
rendus chez le curé du village
c'est ce village de saint siméon saint
siméon qui est d'ailleurs le protecteur
du bétail c'est ce village que marie
laure augry est allé visiter
deschamps sans maïs des nuages qu'ils en
finissent pas de crevettes une terre
craquelée à perte de vue
c'est ce que les normands appelle la
piste sèche il faut creuser loin pour
trouver une zone d'humilité en ce moment
dans le sol tel qu'il est là au moins
une vingtaine de centimètres c'est en
creux on avoue trouve déjà il ya
toujours rien voilà un grain de maïs
qu'est qu'a germé
quand il est venu un petit orage depuis
que le germe il a séché depuis quoi
alors ça veut dire que tout le champ est
comme ça par celui qu'elle vc la pomme
s'est perdu c'est terminé pour pour ce
champ là seul le miracle de l'appui s'il
intervenait avant une semaine
vous êtes encore éviter le pire affirme
les agriculteurs beaucoup sont résignés
mais d'autres espèrent encore ils savent
qu'en 1921 les grandes sécheresses ce
miracle de l'appui a eu lieu après une
procession dédiée à saint siméon
c'est tout au moins ce que racontent les
anciens c'est pourquoi ils sont venus
nombreux
demandez à leur curé d'organiser une
messe et une procession dimanche dernier
j'étais plus de 2000 venus prier
saintignon le protecteur du bétail
et
alors si malgré les prières il ne pleut
pas monsieur le curé quelle conclusion
vous donner on reste à la merci de dieu
c'est dieu qui le met cela et s'assumer
on invoque saint-siméon pour qu'il
intercède auprès de dieu pour nous
maintenant on laisse dieu juge vous êtes
venus prier saint siméon pourquoi
contenir la pluie va seulement voilà que
leurs épaules les cols pour les chocobos
tout c'est malgré les prières il ne
pleut pas on subit là un accès à fait
maison ou appartement
on scrute les nuages et puis on tape sur
le baromètre tous les jours voir si ça
va mais c'est ça n'a pas l'air de
vouloir changer
et puis l'obsession c'est quand on va
dans un champ et qui voit des lettres
vous fait de la paille ou des vaches qui
sont en train de me gay parce que enfin
cette sécheresse est en effet dramatique
pour les éleveurs bien que nous payons
plus nourrir leur bétail et déjà leurs
vaches donnent moitié moines de l'est et
pour certains le seul recours et
l'abattage
surprise à madrid ont pensé que le
compte de mon tricot l'actuel ministre
des affaires étrangères du gouvernement
espagnol allait être nommé par le roi
juan carlos pour succéder à monsieur
arias navarro et bien non c'est monsieur
adolfo suarez qui vient d'être désigné
par le roi comme nouveau chef de
gouvernement espagnol monsieur suarez
est jeune il est âgé de 43 ans il est
membre du gouvernement espagnol
depuis un an et il était en 1968 le
directeur de la première chaîne de
télévision espagnole avant d'accéder au
poste de directeur général de la radio
et de la télévision et ce en 1969 on
pense généralement
cette nomination donne l'impression que
le roi a choisi avec monsieur suarez un
deuxième gouvernement de transition
plutôt qu'un véritable premier
gouvernement de la monarchie monsieur
suarez porte en effet la marque du
mouvement qui était le parti unique sous
franco même s'il n'est pas semble-t-il
parmi les plus conservateurs de ce
mouvement
la tentative de putsch a bien échouer au
soudan cet après-midi le général
d'imerys et en effet adressé à la nation
par un message radiodiffusé
il a affirmé que le putsch avait été
écrasée que l'unité et le progrès du
pays avait été la cible des rebelles le
général ni mairie a également remercié
les soudanais pour leur contribution à
l'échec du complot c'est d'ailleurs le
président soudanais lui même qui aurait
dirigé les forces loyalistes engagées
contre les rebelles on ignore si les
combats se poursuivent encore à l'heure
actuelle quoi qu'il en soit il semble
bien maintenant que le président ni
mairie et repris les choses en main
à 48 heures du sommet franco allemand de
hambourg le chancelier helmut schmidt
s'est efforcé vous l'avez sans doute vu
dans notre édition de 13h de
dédramatiser les difficultés qui avaient
surgi entre les deux pays il ya quelques
temps se souvient que chancelier fédéral
avait provoqué une assez vive réaction
du gouvernement français par certaines
de ses déclarations sur le gaullisme
pour tf1 il a expliqué que l'idée de
participation souhaitée par le général
de gaulle correspondait aux besoins de
la france et il a ajouté que les
relations franco allemandes étaient en
très bon état
dans un nouvel extrait de cette
interview recueillie en allemagne
fédérale par bernard wolker le
chancelier ouest allemand va maintenant
par l'est en particulier de ses
relations personnelles avec monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing
le champ chez les cheminots ne craint
pas les prochaines élections son parti
est plus que jamais unie derrière lui
comme on l'a vu au dernier congrès à
dortmund les sondages d'opinion montrent
que les électeurs allemands trouvent
helmut schmidt énergique et lui savent
gré d'avoir maîtriser l'inflation et
maintenu la paix sociale il était donc
intéressant de demander aux chanceux les
fumis ce qu'il pense de la situation
sociale et aussi de la situation
économique de la
que pensez-vous des structures sociales
de la france y est il y à des injustices
partenaires je pense que nous avons eu
de la chance en allemagne avec le
développement de notre ordre social
parce que nous avions un mouvement
syndical unitaire et non pas des
millions de syndicalistes et vos dates
qui se sont combattus dans différentes
organisations
je crois que cela est une condition très
importante je serais pour une
progression régulière de l'ordre social
0 très franchement que pensez-vous de
l'économie française et en livrant une
seule phrase choc
je crois que l'économie française à
demain sont solides qu'ils ont envie
franck rac 1 0 la france est un pays
très riche
m ça dézingue enfance et une économie
très forte qui se base sur l'assiduité
l'esprit inventif et le sens de
l'organisation
le budget de l'état français
les finances publiques en france font
vraisemblablement parmi les mieux
ordonner de tous les grands états
européens
cela a toujours été mon impression donc
je ne vois pas pourquoi tu feras ce jeu
on devrait critiquer l'économie
française au contraire je crois et c'est
démontré par l'actuelle récession
mondiale dont nous sentons de sortir
je crois que la france et d'une les
forces qui aide les autres états à
sortir de la grande dépression
conjoncturel dans laquelle est tombé le
monde arabe
que pensez vous de ces pronostics qui
annonce que l'économie française sera
bientôt plus forte que les gains amis de
votre pays et carette à personne je
pense que c'est tout à fait possible
long terme
cela dépend beaucoup démographie de
l'évolution de la démographie dans les
deux pays et dans toute l'europe
cela dépend également du développement
de l'île
cassure d'ici 10 20 ou 30 ans le
développement économique sera tout à
fait fonction du système d'éducation
actuellement appliquée dans les écoles
c'est valable pour l'italie pour
l'angleterre pour la france et pour
l'allemagne à bab mais nous avons un
capital dont je vois les économies
française et allemande
tout à fait dans la même catégorie elles
sont les économies là visibles d'europe
et en même temps ce sont les deux plus
grandes
quant à leur volume les industriels
français sont ils aussi efficace que les
industriels allemands
les affiches en français ne sont pas
plus bêtes que les allemands ni les
banquiers allemands plus bête que les
banquiers à paris ni les ingénieurs
allemands plus intelligent ou moins
intelligents que les français c'est la
même classe la seule différence que je
pense en savoir et celle de
l'organisation syndicale
cela me semble jouer un rôle important
le fait que les syndicats français soit
plus politisé pas qu'il soit trop
politisé mais ils ne sont pas unifiées
il ya presse de grève en allemagne est
cependant les augmentations de salaires
les aides sont apportées
le salaire moyen est actuellement
supérieur en allemagne à se quitter dans
france cela parce que nos syndicats
étaient suffisamment fort pour ne pas
avoir besoin de prouver continuellement
la force par des grèves et des
manifestations
ils ont obtenu lors des négociations
avec le patronat tout ce qui était
possible sans pour autant tuer la vache
à lait où on était coup de souffle à
vous l'avez constaté dans cet extrait
d'interview le chancelier fédéral helmut
schmidt n'a pas parlé de ses rapports
avec le président de la république il a
parlé pour d'ailleurs les races et des
compliments de l'économie française et
de la situation sociale à france 2 la
france est dans une prochaine édition
que nous vous présenterons interview
monsieur helmut schmidt évoque ses
relations personnelles qui sont
d'ailleurs très bonne explique-t-il avec
monsieur giscard d'estaing pour célébrer
le bicentenaire de la naissance des
états unis les américains vont organiser
demain
une immense fête à la dimension de leur
pays avec 24 heures d'avancé washington
a commémoré l'événement aujourd'hui avec
une énorme parade qui a rassemblé près
d'un million de personnes et c'est
évidemment demain 4 juillet deux cent
ans jour pour jour après la déclaration
de l'indépendance que les manifestations
seront les plus spectaculaires à new
york en particulier les plus grands
voiliers du monde défileront en
remontant l'hudson le président ford
assistera cette cérémonie avant de
rentrer le soir à washington pour
admirer le feu d'artifice géant qui a
d'ailleurs été préparé par une
entreprise française dans les rues de
new york à la veille de cet événement la
fanfare des beaux-arts a fait
véritablement sensations le célèbre
orchestre c'est bien sûr rendu aux états
unis à l'occasion du bicentenaire et
pour symboliser aussi par la musique
populaire la contribution française à
l'indépendance américaine
toute la journée d'hier cette fanfare
des beaux-arts à jouer césaire et ses
refrains favoris nous la retrouvons ici
devant la statue de lincoln avec son
apparence un peu folklorique et l'une de
ses rengaines qui font d'habitude danser
les parisiens chaque année au soir du 14
juillet
demain soir au cours de notre édition
19h45 tf1 célébrera également cette
commémoration dans une interview
recueillie par notre envoyé spécial
michel ans frôle le président des états
unis monsieur gerald ford adressera en
effet un message à la france nous
rendrons compte en même temps de
l'ensemble des cérémonies anniversaires
de ce bicentenaire des états unis à 20
ans le suédois bjorn borg a remporté
aujourd'hui à wimbledon sa victoire la
plus prestigieuse peut-être bien sûr il
avait déjà gagné les championnats
internationaux de france de roland
garros bien sûr la tête de l'équipe de
suède il avait remporté la coupe davis
l'an dernier mais ce titre de wimbledon
c'est une consécration incontestable
d'autant que borde a gagné ce tournoi
sans perdre un set une performance
rarissime face
anastase qu'il avait eu 6 4 6 2 9 7 dong
a fait preuve une fois de plus de ses
étonnantes qualités s'il ne possède pas
le tennis artistique de son adversaire
roumain il a en revanche une force de
caractère et une volonté de
concentration qui surprennent chaque
jour davantage on disait board fatigué
et émoussé par le tour du monde
permanent qu'il effectue depuis
plusieurs années et bien il a surpris
une fois de plus et il a bien montré
qu'il était sans doute le meilleur
joueur de sa génération alain escoubet
grand brun bronzé superbe souple
malicieux et facétieux voici ilie
nastase 30 ans l'idole des femmes qui
jouent au tennis et des autres au code
qu'il était beau il y cet après midi sur
le central de wimbledon
grand blond barbu cheveux au vent
austère et sévère voici bjorn borg 20
ans l'idole des mines est de 7 à 27 ans
ou god qu'il était pathétique dionne
lorsqu il pulvérisait son abdomen
atteint d'une séquelle maladie avec son
produit miracle borg au tennis de rêve
contre nastase au tennis d'extase
qui donc pouvait l'emporter nastase
pensait-on car plus âgés et plus
expérimentés plus fin et plus fun
d'ailleurs regardez
mais si les pronostics sont une chose la
réalité en est une autre
inflexible impassible impassable board
cet après-midi jouait mieux que le
roumain
au tennis lorsqu'on est débordé l'on ait
découragé déconcentré l'on pensait
exactement ce qui est arrivé anastase
qui après avoir perdu le set qu'il ne
fallait pas perdre le premier à oublier
parce que tout de ce qu'il savait faire
pour s'incliner dans les deux suivants
borg vainqueur de wimbledon à 20 ans
sans laisser un seul set
cela peut paraître étonnant mais y at-il
vraiment aujourd'hui au monde un joueur
qui soit meilleur que lui
un bien beau match le britannique james
wan sur mclaren et l'autrichien niki
lauda sur ferrari ont réalisé les
meilleurs temps aux essais sur le
circuit du castellet à la veille du
grand prix de france
le français patrick de payet sur tyrrell
et le suisse clay regazzoni sur ferrari
ont réussi les 3e et 4e temps le grand
prix de france qui est la huitième
épreuve de la saison comptant pour le
championnat du monde des conducteurs
sera dominé de main par deux
interrogations qui pourra battre dit
qu'il a au dha quelle sera la
performance des tirets la cire ou qui
avait remporté brillamment le dernier
grand prix de formule 1 disputé en suède
à la veille de la première grande étape
de montagne du tour de france les 120
rescapés de l'épreuve se sont reposés
aujourd'hui a dit venus les mares peau
est d'ailleurs un bien grand mot puisque
la plupart d'entre eux sont allés se
chauffer les muscles ce matin dans le
col de la faucille cette étape de demain
qui conduira les coureurs à l'alpe
d'huez après 258 kilomètres de route
sera peut-être un grand jour pour
raymond poulidor
le brave toutou qui est toujours en pet
au hit parade de la popularité est pour
l'instant 5e du classement général à
trois minutes trente et une secondes du
belge martens et et connaissant ses
qualités de grimpeur
certains n'hésitent pas à le voir déjà
conquérir le maillot jaune demain soir
poulidor occuperait ainsi la première
place pour la première fois de sa
carrière et c'est je crois un rêve qu'il
ne cesse de caresser depuis bien des
années
quelles sont donc aujourd'hui ses
espoirs à 40 ans peut-il encore tenir
tête au géant du peloton voilà des
questions que bernard giroux était
l'épousé à raymond poulidor à papeete
tabarly voici pp poulidor le public a
fait facilement le rapprochement est
avec ces sportifs de 40 ans toute la
france se met à rêver
louis d'or est toujours aussi plébiscité
est la foule pour l'instant lui restent
fidèles
cinquième au général et 2e français pour
tous demeurent toutefois réaliste
un bilan personnel je dirais pour moi il
est très positif
j'ai fait cette première ils ont partie
première semaine du tour de france qui a
été évidemment peut-être la plus facile
bien qu'il y ait eu quand même cette
chaleur persiste 1 2 qui se joue un rôle
dans ce tour de france mais dix ans
meurt voici cinquième au classement
général évidemment il reste maintenant
la phase la plus importante aborder les
certains de vos supporteurs ou adhésion
avec le maillot jaune
après tout c'était impossible je ne
rajeunis pas si je n'y pense pas pour
moi mon classement actuel 10 en or et
conforte largement et tous ses
supporters évidemment ça peut être
surpris de cette place que j'occupe
actuellement et il ne voit pour cette
raison peut-être maillot jaune
généralement loin qu'on ne réussit pas
ils m'appuient dame est aujourd'hui le
limousin a effectué une cinquantaine de
kilomètres nous allons avoir quatre
étapes vraiment de deux montagnes avec
des grands comptes
et là je voulais vraiment aller dans
l'inconnu jusqu'à présent
nous disons et col de 3e catégorie de
moyenne importance je les ai très bien
passé mais rien à voir avec les cols de
première catégorie et en ce qui concerne
nos objectifs ils sont maintenant un peu
plus précis kobo peur disent on est
jeune mais objectif c'est de terminer à
une place honorable je ne sais pas
laquelle se se sont impartis la fonction
des adversaires comment ils vont marcher
peut se révéler des adversaires qu'on ne
découragea pas mais pas aux dés pères au
départ mais qu'apple ou une place
honorable
disons dans les dix premiers selon me
destremau leader en bref avec marie
laure augry les autres journaux nouvelle
de ce journal à kampala rien de nouveau
pour les 105 otages restants qui sont
maintenant tous réunis dans une même
salle expiration de l'ultimatum est
toujours fixée à demain à 11 heures
selon l'ambassadeur de somalie à kampala
les négociations entre le commando pro
palestiniens et les gouvernements
français ont fait des progrès
substantiels quant au président amin
dada actuellement à port louis pour
assister au sommet de l'organisation
unité africaine
ils devraient rentrer ce soir en ouganda
pour reprendre les négociations avec le
commando pro palestinien en argentine 15
personnes en argentine 15 personnes ont
été tuées aujourd'hui à buenos aires
selon la police les victimes pourraient
appartenir à des groupes subversifs
leurs corps ont été découverts criblés
de balles quant à l'attentât à la bombe
commis hier après midi contre la police
fédérale 2b lozère il aurait fait selon
le dernier bilan officiel 18 morts 66
blessés dont onze grièvement
tout de suite après l'attentât le
quartier a mis immédiatement été bouclé
de nombreuses arrestations ont été
opérées au liban malgré un nouveau
cessez-le-feu le sang le 51e les combats
continuent chrétiens d'une part
palestiniens et libano progressis de
l'autre s'accusent réciproquement
d'avoir violé ce nouvel accord
ce cessez-le-feu a cependant été
acceptée par les palestiniens
progressiste mais sous deux conditions
le respect de cette mesure par notre
parti et l'arrêt de toute opération
militaire à tal el attar meurtre ou
accident c'est le doute qui subsiste
après la mort d'un conseiller municipal
de toulon de corps de monsieur alfred
moreno a été découvert hier sur les
rochers littoral tout le
et le conseiller municipal aurait
succombé à une fracture du crâne
consécutive à une chute depuis une
falaise de 20 mètres l'hypothèse du
suicide étant écartée il reste aux
policiers déterminer s'il s'agit d'un
meurtre ou bien d'un accident calcul les
tradition oblige il est vraisemblable
que beaucoup d'estivants iront cette
année chercher un peu de fraîcheur au
fond des mers plus de 50000 plongeur
sous-marin devrait d'après les
statistiques pratiquer cette année leur
sport favori ils apprendront sans doute
avec admiration le nouveau record de
plongée établi cette nuit par un tueur
qui est resté dans l'eau écoutez bien
pendant trente sept heures 3 minutes et
30 secondes
le nouveau recordman est un ancien
commando de la marine turque il a 35 ans
et il est également entraîneur de
l'équipe nationale de judo mais il
serait bien sûr dangereux de vouloir
même approché ce record on ne devient
pas aussi résistant que le commandant
cousteau en quelques jours les plongeurs
sous marins savent bien qu'il est
nécessaire d'apprendre et d'assimiler
les principales recommandations d'usagé
des recommandations que christian
brincourt qui a mené une enquête
minutieuse nous présente maintenant
cette année plus de 50 mille français
vont découvrir les joies de la plongée
sous-marine et c'est pourquoi nous avons
cru bon de demander à guy poulet qui est
instructeur national est l'un des
meilleurs plongeurs de france quelques
précisions sur la préparation à la
plongée guy à qui s'adresse la plongée
sous-marine et on peut dire un très
vaste éventail de personnes de niveau
social tout à fait différent en résumé
c'est les gens qui souhaitent découvrir
le monde du silence ou le sixième
continent et on peut situer leur âge
entre 12 13 ans pour les débuts et 73
ans est notre joueur le plus âgé dans la
région avant de découvrir les fonds
sous-marins guy je pense est
indispensable de procéder à une
excellente et messieurs du syndical
pourquoi oui je crois que c'est
indispensable parce que cela pratique de
ce sport peut être assujettie à des
contre indications médicales que parfois
les pratiquants ne peuvent pas soupçonné
par exemple une incompatibilité au
niveau des oreilles et des sinus pour
pouvoir équilibrer des séquelles de
maladies pulmonaires ou l'asthme ou un
diabète accentué commence à faire chaud
maintenant que la meilleure façon
d'enseigner la plongée c'est de partir
sous la mer c'est pour ça que nous
allons y aller allez-y conjoint la
vulgarisation de la découverte du monde
sous marin ainsi aujourd'hui un grand
nombre de sportifs à tenter l aventure
qui les conduira vers le monde du
silence
la plongée plus qu'un sport est une
technique qui demande aux hommes qui la
pratiquent tous les sens lui cite des
problèmes posés et des moyens utilisés
pour les résoudre
qui dit technique matériel de plongée
donc budget vu des moyens pour applaudir
débutant est d'environ 150 francs pour
un plongeur confirmé environs de 950
francs plus bien sûr les bouteilles et
des tendeurs qui valent environ 600
francs en france semblable à ce centre
international de plongée du golf devant
700 clubs fédéraux sont à la disposition
du public et enseigne la plongée sous la
direction de moniteurs nationaux dans la
plupart de ces clubs
l'équipement et le matériel lourd sans
fourrure liées au futur plongeurs cela
dit le vacancier type qui décidera de
consacrer 15 jours à l'initiation de la
plongée devra compter deux saisons pour
apprendre à plonger et 40 francs par le
s'il a plongé à l'air comprimé et non
pas à l'oxygène reste un sport
passionnant il suffit que des règles
impératives établie par la fédération
d'études et de sports sous-marins une
règle d'or ne plongez jamais seul
vérifiez et entretenez votre matériel
évitez le bricolage
et n'oubliez pas le code de
communication qui est le garant de votre
sécurité
dix poules est en fait la démonstration
mois
montées descentes et
arrêtez-vous tout va bien ça ne va pas
très bien
je vais passer ma réserve
j'ai du mal à passer ma réserve je n'ai
plus d'air
bien nous venons de donner quelques
conseils de prudence pour futurs
pratiquants de la plongée mais je pense
que l'on peut également précisé guy que
la plongée reste un très beau sport
bien évidemment si vous aviez un conseil
à leur donner
que voyez vous dire eh bien je pense que
en plongée il faut surtout se souvenir
qu'il est préférable d'avoir du plomb
dans la tête qu'à la ceinture bien nous
y pensons ce journal est maintenant
terminée prochaines informations avec
marie laure augry encore elle ce soir
aux alentours de 23h30 merci de nous
avoir prêté attention
bonne soirée